Michael is in Arkansas hey Michael
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey Dave thanks for taking my call today
sure what's up hey uh with the kernel
virus my company has reduced our salary
by 20 percent permanently back into well
they say for three or four weeks but
back in 2008 I wasn't at the company yet
but they said that they did this and
they said that it was going to be
temporary and it ended up being
permanent so my question for you is how
long would you stay at the company if it
doesn't end up being just temporary it's
more permanent or what conversations you
might have with management yeah well I
mean if they say it's temporary and then
they come back later and say oh no it's
permanent there would have to be reasons
for that and you would have to not be
able to get a job for more than that
what do you make after the capade cut
after the pay cut I'm at seventy-five
thousand okay so you're making like
ninety five thousand bucks correct
doing what CPA okay so if you can be a
CPA somewhere else 495 and they won't
raise your salary back up you would go
take the new job right correct I guess I
just didn't know this if they said after
three weeks if you would say well I'll
give you two or three more weeks or if
you yeah I would just start looking I
mean unless there's something else wrong
there another reason but if the only
thing is is that their revenues are down
and they're trying to survive by not
laying off a bunch of people instead
giving everybody a temporary cut that's
good everybody gets a little pain
instead of a few gets the whole pain we
talked about doing something somewhere
around here if we had reached a revenue
problem thank goodness we haven't we may
still but I don't think we will and so
you know if you see revenues coming back
up assigns the revenues coming back up
around there and then they don't raise
it back up you know then you I would ask
about it and go you know because I think
I can make ninety five over to another
place right
Michael how old are you Michael
30 years old 30 years old yeah um I
agree with Dave and now I'm gonna add
this to it him before you jump the man I
want you to really set back sit back and
think about just a coach of the company
one thing that we have here is if Dave
did come to me and say hey personalities
we gotta take a pay cut you know the
culture here is just amazing you know so
I love this place I do you love where
you work
do you enjoy the culture so don't just
go chasing for another twenty thousand
dollars which I get it money is
important but make sure that you're
leaving because you don't like the place
as well but if you do like it hang
around and trust the company because I
would do that with Dave I trust Dave I
love where we are and I'm not here just
for the Paycheck that I'm blessed to
have so that's just something to
consider as well hey Anthony I need to
talk to you about so now I would give
them a few weeks and then I would start
having just they need to give you lots
of communication they owe you lots of
communication about the timeline on this
so when are you gonna raise this back up
and what are you basing that on if they
say well we're basing it on revenues and
here's what revenues are doing and
you're okay with waiting that because a
lot of places have had to do that kind
of a thing and so you know but but you
know this time next year if they haven't
raised it back up I'm looking for a job
because of I then this should be
completely completely completely
recovered